hey everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
signal peptidases which is a kind of an
enzyme before we get started make sure
that you hit subscribe and hit the bell
icon for notifications so you can get
more free study videos and i also want
to make sure that you are able to find
my free
notes
to use as study materials so look in the
description below to get the tiny url
link and you'll be able to get a picture
on a free pdf of the final board with
all of the answers spelled in so don't
forget to go get that
let's go ahead and get started and talk
about signal peptidases
these are membrane enzymes meaning that
they're enzymes that are present in
membranes so i've drawn it in this kind
of pink color right here the sp ace
which is an abbreviation that you
sometimes see for signal peptidases so
it's in the membrane which is the black
line and it's an enzyme remember an
enzyme is a protein that's a biological
catalyst it catalyzes
um
chemical reactions if you want to know
more about enzymes
then
please see my video on introduction to
enzymes to see more about how they work
so these are membrane enzymes and what
they do is they cleave
you know cleave or like cut
in terminal
signal
peptides
off of certain polypeptides so what does
this mean here we've got inside the cell
polypeptide i've drawn it in purple
and it's got what's called a signal
peptide that i've drawn in red that's
attached to it so basically when this
polypeptide was translated this signal
peptide was part of that translation and
the reason it's important is because
it's like a it's like a homing device or
like a like a location device
where these uh signal peptides we put
onto secreted proteins like proteins
that are intended to be secreted are
made inside the cell and are intended to
be secreted outside the cell or
some membrane proteins so proteins again
that are made inside the cell and down
in the cytoplasm and that need to be
moved from the place where they're made
up to be a part of the membrane so for
these secreted proteins and some
membrane proteins they're going to have
this um
this signal peptide that again it's like
it's a sequence that tells the cell
where this thing is supposed to go
but then once it gets up to the membrane
and it's either being secreted or
integrated into the membrane that signal
peptide needs to be cleaved off it needs
to be cut off and so that is necessary
for that polypeptide
to be able to fold
into its mature functional form that
signal peptide is going to be cut off
and it is the signal peptidase or the
space sometimes it's called that
that makes that cleavage happen
so these signal peptidases are found in
prokaryotes
and they're also found in the
endoplasmic reticulum and chloroplasts
and mitochondria
of various eukaryotes
so these are very very widely
distributed throughout all of the
domains of life very important to get
that signal peptide off so the rest of
the polypeptide can fold into its mature
functional form
now
all
known signal pet today says all the ones
that we know about are serene proteases
serine is one of the amino acids that
you may be familiar with
if you want to learn more about amino
acids and i do have a video
um on like a structure of amino acids
that you could check out if you want to
but the reason they're called serine
proteases you know there are protease
that means they cut a protein right uh
and they have a serine the anti
certain anti the amino acid serine is
part of their
active site the active site of their
enzyme if you want to know more about
active sites check out that video on
enzymes
now why
why am i excited about signal peptidases
i mean what they do is cool already on
its own but also a reason i think that
you should be excited about signal
peptidases as well is because they are
considered to be
a great
antibiotic
target
what does this mean
antibiotics target
different things in uh in bacterial
cells
okay so they will
target like the ribosome or they will
target the cell wall or they will target
uh the flagella some um because some
pathogens will have flagella
and
it's possible that the signal pep today
says
that bacteria use the bacteria require
we could potentially find an antibiotic
to inhibit those signal peptidases and
fight bacterial infections now at this
point at the point that i am filming
this video in early 2022
there are no approved antibiotics that
target signal peptidases
there are some that are like in trials
like some aerolomycins
but that's still something that we're
looking for
now why why is the signal peptidase of
bacteria such an attractive target for
antibiotics well first
it's essential
okay it is essential
to prokaryotes
so any
bacterial infection every single one of
those bacteria cells relies on a
functional signal peptidase
for to to um to sort of survive and to
replicate
so it's very essential now of course
it's essential for eukaryotes as well
right and humans are eukaryotes but
the signal peptidases and prokaryotes
are sufficiently
different
from their eukaryotic counterparts this
allows us to search for
selective toxicity and what that means
is
scientists are looking for a compound an
antibiotic
that would inhibit the activity of
prokaryotic
in this case we're talking about
bacteria right
of the bacterial signal peptidases but
without inhibiting the action of the
human eukaryotic signal peptidases so
finding an antibiotic that is
selectively toxic that will hurt the
bacterial
signal peptidase without affecting the
the human
signal peptidase
um and then also another reason it's
such a great antibiotic target is
because there's relatively easy access
to it remember that it's in the membrane
okay in the membrane
including the membrane of the bacteria
and its active site is actually out here
it's active site is on the
what we call that extra cytoplasmic face
on the outside so it's just it's you
know it's easier if i kind of
i'm just gonna draw a little dot in
there you know it's easier to get to to
get to that active site for an inhibitor
an antibiotic to come in and bind to
that active site and keep the signal
peptidase from doing its job because
that active site is on the outside of
the cell
so there's that relatively easy access
the active site is in the outer
leaflet of the
of the membrane
now i do want to draw your attention
really quick to a different enzyme not a
signal peptidase but what we call the
signal peptide peptidases sorry i know
it's a similar word i did not choose to
name them but the signal peptide
peptidases or spps
are a sparkle proteases
a sparkle proteases this just means that
it's in a different family of proteases
from the serine proteases rather than
having a serine amino acid in the active
site they've got an aspartate amino acid
in the active site and these perform a
second cleavage step to degrade the
signal peptide okay
so i've drawn this up here hopefully
this will kind of bring everything
together you've got a polypeptide that's
been made synthesized in the cytoplasm
of the cells inside the cell so we've
got this polypeptide that's been
translated from the mrna
and it's got this signal peptide that
helps it get up to the membrane and it's
going to basically go across the
membrane to be translocated from this
side of the membrane to this side of the
membrane through um there's like a
there's a pathway called the sec pathway
there's another one called the tat
pathway through one of those
to kind of get out and and what's gonna
happen is you know i've drawn this
pathway as basically like a tunnel
across the membrane the second tap
pathways they're actually more
complicated than that they require um
multiple you know protein components
but what happens is the polypeptide
exits the cell and see the signal
peptide is still like
anchoring it to the membrane
and in order for it to be fully released
secreted or if it's intended to be a
membrane protein for it to be able to
kind of
get to the right orientation in the
membrane and then for them to fold into
their functional mature forms that
signal peptide has got to be cut off and
that's what that pink
i've drawn i've drawn it in paint of
course in real life it's not pink
the signal peptidase or spas is there in
the membrane to make that cut so just to
cut you know right there to release that
polypeptide and allow it to fold into a
functional metric form
and then you've got the signal peptide
kind of hanging out in the membrane and
that's where the second one comes in
the signal peptide peptidase again
that's a different kind of protease
right i've drawn it right here in blue
and it cleaves the signal peptide and
once the signal peptide has been cleaved
um it it basically is kind of degraded
and it it falls out of the of the
membrane
and then you've got your functional
protein over there so that is the action
of the signal peptidases thank you for
watching biology professor remember to
subscribe make sure you get that tiny
url in the description so you get free
study notes thanks for watching and i
will see you next time